Amazon founder and CEO Jeff Bezos...
...has become the world's third richest person for the first time.
According to Forbes magazine, Bezos passed Warren Buffett,...
...the chairman and chief executive of Berkshire Hathaway Incorporated.
Bezos' fortune was 65.3 billion dollars as of 4:30 p.m. Eastern time on Thursday,...
...compared with Buffett's 64.9 billion dollars.
Microsoft Corporation co-founder Bill Gates remained the world's richest person,...
...at 77.7 billion dollars.
Spain's Amancio Ortega, who founded the Zara clothing chain, and owner of Inditex,...
...was second at 72.7 billion dollars.
Facebook Incorporated co-founder and chief executive Mark Zuckerberg was fifth at 54 billion dollars.